Toyota's German headquarters in Cologne
has been hard at work converting an old
Hall it's a beehive of activity this is
now Toyota's first Museum outside of
Japan for many of the exhibits the car
maker can thank the avid collector Peter
picket he started as a Toyota dealer in
Passau in the early 1970s and over the
years built up one of the largest
private collections of Toyotas anywhere
in 1999 he opened his own Toyota Museum
when he died in 2016 Toyota Motorsports
stepped in to prevent the collection
from being broken up first the museum
pieces were lovingly repaired and
restored then pushed into the hall on
muscle power and maneuvered into their
designated spots among them is this FJ
45 Land Cruiser converted into a small
fire engine
one after the other the exhibits are
pushed into place in the hall the vast
array of models ranges from the Toyota
1000 subcompact and its successor the
starlet to the compacts
sedans and several generations of
co-pays to the Land Cruiser series
around 70 pieces from every face of
Toyotas history make up the collection
now safe in its permanent home in
Cologne it's to be open to the public on
special occasions
on opening night about 100 invited
guests and pay the patients family got
the opportunity to inspect the complete
collection the pea shots and Toyota
Germany's President Tom Fuchs officially
opened the museum with a traditional
ribbon-cutting Tom Fuchs points out that
he runs a car company and that he's
crazy about cars
Toyota Germany has always been well
aware that they didn't have any vintage
models here to show off so when Peter
pica died they wanted to make sure his
collection would survive intact for
posterity that's how the Toyota
collection was born and it will preserve
an honor Peter patient's legacy
his son remembers that it all started
around 1979 his father was a businessman
body and soul and he recognized the
opportunity to pioneer a new market in
1971 Toyota was virtually unknown in
West Germany and he got the idea to
establish the brand and get it moving
that's when he started collecting the
cars and he kept at it until shortly
before he passed on the Museum in
Cologne not only includes vehicles
donated by Peter Piot but also a few
from Toyota Germany's initial collection
and a few other private sources
Peter jr. adds that they came from all
over Germany from private owners and
other dealers people approached him and
said they'd be happy to loan their cars
but they didn't want to sell them they
were glad to see them in a museum where
nothing could happen to them the pride
of the collection is the Toyota 2000gt
the definitive coupe a limited to just
351 units that achieved world fame on
streets and tracks in the early 1960s
and went on to write motion picture
history in roadster form in the James
Bond movie
you only live twice race cars like the
veteran lmp1 can also be seen here as
well as this 1999 Toyota Corolla WRC the
racer steered by former toyota company
rally driver he sold a holder eat he's
older has been with Toyota for a long
time now but it's still something
special for her to see this or that
model in the flesh
you